Listen to my aria
[music] It
's said to be an angel's singing voice
There's no youths at all
[music]
Attila's first year at Boo Boo station I won't rush into land fortune
Your favorite sign Sturm Envelope spreads in your heart here I will definitely
I promised in my heart that I wouldn't rush into such a big deal, but if I get tangled up, I'll stick in as much as I got tangled up
, huh
?  Is it okay if I'm not
a nerd? I came here to break the dojo because it
hurts and I'm a
kid.  I've been told that I'm God What's wrong? It's
difficult
today  So you can buy it and say it to the main body, and everyone will definitely want to pie together.
I just wanted to eat it.
I'm a mother